coming clean with voters and revealing
his true stance on packing the supreme
court
well sort of the former vp announcing
he'll appoint a commission
to study reforming the high court if he
wins
i will ask them to over a 180 days come
back to me with recommendations
as to how to uh reform the court system
because it's getting out of whack
so you're telling us you're going to
study this issue about whether to pack
the court no whether there's a number of
alternatives that are go
well beyond packing this is a live ball
oh it is a live ball
no it is a live ball we're going to have
to do that and you're going to find
there's a lot of conservative
constitutional scholars understanding as
well
man that guy looked out of gas i don't
know gut felt i mean why doesn't he
appoint a commission to find out what
he's gonna have for dinner
i mean make a decision you're gonna be
the leader of the free world you need a
commission for this
well i mean he's dealing with a hard
left contingent in his party so he could
i
actually uh start a commission on
capitalism do we still need capitalism
how about landlords or rent or uh the
police department just have commissions
for everything
he it perfectly reveal his answer
perfectly reveals that his spine
is actually a weather vein yeah and it's
pretty sad
because he uh he should be taking a
stand against the practice that could
essentially undermine our entire
republic
uh and destroy this country court
packing would turn it into a one-party
nation
but he acted in a way like the road
runner
he saw no way out so he painted a tunnel
opening on the wall
and he turned and he ran right into it
unfortunately he's not the road runner
so he flattened himself juan why can't
joe just say yeah we're not gonna pack
the court
uh you know when i win if there's an
opening i'll fill it
uh you know to my mind joe biden's an
institutionalist
jesse and he's often said way back he
wasn't in favor of any expansion of the
number of seats on the court
but i think that at the moment you know
the gop
is throwing the whole court system out
of whack
as he put it by stacking it and now we
have a court
that's unbalanced you have a six to
three court right now
that looks like it could overturn
abortion rights in this country they
would overturn the affordable care act
and take away protections from people
with pre-existing conditions
it would absolutely absolutely favor big
business
over the american people
don't destroy the court this is an old
point
it doesn't matter winning elections greg
because president obama won twice
and he nominated someone and then the
republicans refused to give that man a
hearing so i believe
he got you know these people through one
we're very nice to you so
to my mind you know he's to take away a
lot of the environmental protections if
you have a court that's so out of whack
and my thought
is you know what this is a pretty sober
and deliberative approach
to something that the country may need
to somehow
get the federal judiciary balanced again
all right well
dana throughout history it's never been
5-4 there's been
six threes there's been you know
different
variations of justices this is nothing
new i'd love to be first in line for the
interview
after amy coney barrett joins the
majority in rejecting the
administration's health care law
suit because by all accounts that is
what's going to happen because it is not
a good lawsuit and they should have
dropped it a long time ago
i just think a commission is another
word for kicking the can down the road
do you remember that um president obama
had the commission on entitlements on
social security
they got all these people like come out
of retirement come help
us do all of this work did all of that
work came up with some pretty thoughtful
ideas actually to help
shore up the social security system but
it was right before the election and
president obama was like yeah no i'm not
for that
yeah this kind of reminds me of
something pence brought up when he was
at the debate
he said uh when when mueller was there
in isis captivity
there was a time where we needed to act
and launch a rescue operation
and obama biden they froze i just don't
think martha he has a decisive
executive leadership style that's going
to suit him to be commander in chief
and make strong decisive decisions
i mean nothing says nothing better than
a commission
right better than saying let's let's
just have a commission
it's the number one best way in
washington to defer something to not
answer a question directly
we know how joe biden stands on this he
made it very clear in the past he said
he was against court packing he said
fdr said it was a bad idea after he
tried it and it failed
and uh he believed that it was a bad
idea as well but now he's talking about
the other options you could have 18-year
terms for instance or you could have
rotating justices
from the federal court system but you
can guarantee that if the shoe were on
the other foot they would not be having
this conversation at all
the chips have fallen where they may
this is the way the system works
the president got an opportunity to pick
someone and the senate was
in the gop majority in this case so they
are putting it through
and i think that amy coney barrack gave
people a lot of reason to think that
policy is not high on the list for the
supreme court
uh they are there for another purpose to
judge whether or not a law is
constitutional
and i think that should give a lot of
people some confidence i don't think
anybody knows
how she would vote on any of these
issues specifically so
um you know we'll see where it goes from
here yes we will